welcome back to New rockstars I'm Eric
Boss and Captain America Brave New World
just got a live braver after secret
Invasion as America and the MCU just
declared war on God sorry to sound like
a cable news host but the United States
president ended secret Invasion by
declaring war on all extraterrestrial
life everywhere not just limiting this
declaration to the squirrels who
attacked him on Earth but also according
to his words including the asgardians
the eternals celestials cree zandarians
ravagers Flora colossi kylosians Cronin
sakarins Titans omnipotent City
residents and Howard the Ducks
despite many of these extraterrestrials
saving our butt in the Battle of Earth
in tiamat's late term report what what
that's what it was in the case of these
Guardians eternals Titans and celestials
these beings have been considered gods
and demigods of the MCU and by calling
them enemy combatants it puts Earth in
the crosshairs that I don't think even
they're ready for so is the MCU Korean
toward another civil war and Brave New
World and Thunderbolts and armor Wars
well I'm gonna break down the current
balance of power in the Marvel Universe
who's mad at home who will align with
who in this Intergalactic war and
whether Earth could survive this there
really should be fed to Galactus by the
way sag after has informed us that
entertainment journalists like us are
allowed to cover TV shows and movies but
we stand with the writers and actors in
their strike to get the fair working
conditions they deserve okay the secret
Innovation finale in its final minutes
finally started to look and sound like a
secret Invasion storyline with a
terrifying address from the U.S
president ritzen that's why tonight I'm
presenting to Congress for immediate
emergency authorization a bill that
designates all off-world born species
enemy combatants
We Know Who You Are
we know how to find you
and we will kill every last one of you
do you really know who they are Mr
President do you know how to fight them
and can you kill someone like Valkyrie
the MCU United States political
relationship with new Asgard is the
first thing I'm really asking about
because the Black Panther were kind of
forever there was a new sticker that
reported U.S president Ritz inside a
trade pact with new Asgard meanwhile
valkyrie's name appeared on the DNA
scanner screen right before graphic and
Gaia fed the adventure DNA vial into
that super scroll machine and I don't
think we saw valkyrie's Powers being
used in particular during that fight but
if the ruler of new Asgard learns that
her blood was harvested from the
battlefield after she fought to save
Earth and I guess suppose everyone in
the universe but she still put her neck
out on the line I don't think Valkyrie
is going to be very happy to find out
her Asgardian DNA was taken and used
this way initially taken by U.S
government workers and really I just
don't think Earth is a good forever home
for the asgardians going forward anyway
and just so we're clear it wasn't just
ads Guardians living in new Asgard and
Avengers end game walking around the
background of that Marina was one of the
sakarin Warriors who joined Korg in Meek
when they left sicar to go to Asgard
during the events of Thor Ragnarok in
Seahawk we met an Alf jaimean light elf
named roona who presumably also lived in
New Asgard and already began clearly to
strain the American justice system
tensions are fraught and one of the
hilarious aspects of secret division was
really the big crisis of the skulls
being unable to find a new Homeworld
other than Earth not only did both the
Guardians of the Galaxy holiday special
and Guardians of the Galaxy vol 3
established nowhere as a perfectly
suitable Refugee Colony that would have
been great for the Scrolls Carol Danvers
herself already found a perfectly
suitable beautiful agriculturally sweet
piece of real estate in the form of the
garden thanos's retirement Planet
adventures in game the planet is
completely empty and would have been
perfect for the Scrolls why not send
them there ah just add this to the list
of things in Avengers end game that
produces a secret Invasion clearly just
kind of forgot about along with a roadie
they said was the Scrolls legs not
working as they crawled out of the Armor
after Thanos attack and Abomination and
ghost not being present in the Battle of
Earth but anyway I bring up the garden
because the garden and nowhere are now
just far better home bases for the MCU
as a whole than Earth is not just
because I think Earth will soon be a
snack for Galactus check out that spicy
video because Earth will soon be mired
in another world war that really none of
these characters gonna have anything to
do with this time all signs are pointing
to this war being fought over Tiamat I
spend all day listening to podcasts
music commentaries interviews sound is
incredibly important for my job and
that's why when I need earbuds I use
raycon raycon's wireless earbuds start
at half the price of other premium audio
Brands they are disrupting the
electronics Industry by making great
sound for everyone raycon earbuds give
you eight hours of play time and 32
hours of battery life total plus
seamless Bluetooth pairing and a more
compact design for a comfortable noise
isolating fit you can control your
earbuds with simple tap functions so
it's easy to toggle between three
customizable sound profiles noise
isolation and awareness mode no matter
what your style there's a set of raycons
for you the come company was co-founded
by Ray J who gets that earbuds our
necessity and an accessory that's why
raycon's come in a range of colors
patterns and options for fit none of
which have dangling wires or stems no
wonder Snoop Dogg's obsessed with raycon
they're great raycon has a 30-day free
return policy so you can try out a pair
risk-free just click the link in the
description box or go to byracon.com new
rockstars to get 50 off your raycon
purchase and thanks again to raycon for
sponsoring this episode let's not forget
Earth being in the crosshairs has really
been a thematic undercurrent running
through the MCU for over a decade back
in the first Avengers film in 2012 Thor
called out Nick Fury for inviting
interplanetary War for meddling with
artifacts like the Tesseract which was
later revealed to be an infinity stone
it is a signal to all the Realms that
the Earth is ready for a higher form of
War a higher form you forced our hands a
similar thing happened again when the
Eternal stopped the emergence of the
celestial teammate whose corpse Still
Remains in the Indian Ocean making it
clear to all extraterrestrial races that
the celestial's divine plan for this
planet was defied and I think this is a
real reason ritzen suddenly declared all
extraterrestrials enemy combatants even
the asgardians he just signed a trade
agreement with it's because he knows
that the remains of Tiamat are extremely
valuable and he wants to keep them in
possession of the people of Earth and
the people of the US of a one of the
removed subplots from Black Panther
forever the reason we had all those
weird extra scenes with the CIA director
Val and the U.S Secretary of State
played by Richard Schiff is that the
original story of this movie was going
to involve a United States invasion of
wakanda and American leadership suddenly
paranoid over acquiring all Precious
Minerals to use for Weaponry I think
this will play directly into armor Wars
the movie we now really need to give us
clarification over roady's scroll
history and his actual reaction to Tony
Stark's death and this would fit in with
rumors that tiemut's corpse contains
adamantium and in Captain America Brave
New World and in Thunderbolts might
become a disputed territory as world
powers fight over the Mining rights of
that adamantium I think president ritzen
doesn't want one of those Nations he has
to go up against either militarily or
even across negotiating table at the U.N
to be new Asgard he doesn't want to have
to fight those goats and the way things
were left in secret evasion scrotie
turned NATO against the United States
the UK is without a prime minister and
Sonia fallsworth is now rising in power
with an extremely powerful Ally in the
form of Gaia and the only country that
might geopolitically align with the
United States would be like naturopor
who is overseen by power broker Sharon
Carter wakanda and talal Khan meanwhile
might be neutral at first but probably
not for long now we do already know that
Captain America 4 Brave New World in
that movie the president will be
Thaddeus Ross Harrison Ford and many
believe that that will become a red Hulk
storyline secret evasion hinted that
Ritson will be a one-term president the
question is will Ritz and be replaced by
death resignation or election and would
it be by someone who opposes his
warmongering or someone even more
extreme well with a nickname like
Thunderbolt you gotta imagine that
President's more hawkish so if the us at
any point considered an invasion of
wakanda and if the US held any kind of
international grudge against wakanda or
I don't know breaking out a political
prisoner of Everett Ross someone who
then was corrupted by the Scrolls their
outspoken enemies at the moment I just
can't imagine wakanda would be able to
stay neutral for that long so let's do
the math there you'd have the United
States in metropore against NATO against
Russia and China because yeah no
versus what condo versus new Asgard and
versus all other planets and gods in the
Marvel Cosmos so yeah assuming president
Red Hulk would go down in that war where
would that leave America with a
president Val with a president real
Roadie with the president Norman Osborne
hey that'd be fun but what would America
look like would it just be co-occupied
by wakanda and new Asgard like in the
man in the high tower comment Down Below
on how you think ritzen's declaration
changed the MCU and why he really made
it because I do think he knew something
about Tiamat when he made that address I
want to thank Brandon Barrick and Eric
Francisco for their help with this video
subscribe to all three channels in the
new rock stars Network you can follow me
on all social platforms thanks for
watching I'll see you next time bye
[Music]
thank you